hello everyone I hope you're still
having a great Saturday now there are a
lot of things you can enjoy in this
world but a few things come close to
watching two elite grandmasters battle
it out in blitz and bullet and such was
the case yesterday on speech Chess
Championship on chess calm
it was the semi-final match between
Hikaru Nakamura and Sergey Karjakin the
winner of this match will face Magnus
Carlsen who already got his ticket to
the finals by defeating Alexander
Grichuk in the semi-finals and it's I
mean it's like watching two gladiators
they're all they're just you know
plunging into the arena and the audience
demands for blood but you know not as
much as everyone wanted since this match
actually got the highest percentage of
draws in the history of speed Chess
Championship almost 40% of the games
were drawn now the you know everyone
thought if Nakamura manages out you know
remain equal in the blitz portion that
he will crush Kerrigan in the bullet
section but in the end in the
five-minute + 2 seconds increment
section and a Kimura one with a result
of 6 to 5 it's only 1 point lead in the
three minutes plus two seconds increment
he won with a result of 5 to 4 also 1
point lead and in the bullet section
where everyone thought that Nakamura
would crush garlic and he defeated him
with a result of 5 and 1/2 to 4 and a
half so only only one point lead in
every segment of the match so quite
interesting and obviously Nakamura will
face Carlsen on the 3rd of January for
the finals of speech Chess Championship
and chess calm I will put a link in the
description to the article by Peter
Dodgers he wrote a nice article about
this match for chess calm so you can
read it there are a lot of interesting
facts about the match and the match up
but I decided to show you one game it's
from the Blitz section where Nakamura
has the white pieces and he plays one b3
now when they said that the Nakamoto
shouldn't play such moves I mean of
course he is probably the greatest
expert of speed chess in the world
experience wise and you know he often
employs weird openings but
they said he shouldn't use such things
against a strong chess player like
Kuryakin
but he does that he remains true to his
styling he plays a 1 B 3 E 5 by Kuryakin
we have so far the names of each Larsen
attack Bishop b2 knight c6 and III an
eye to f6 by kurakin Bishop to b5 which
is often the idea when you play this b3
Bishop b2 Bishop d6 now Knight e3 e4 and
/ Knight to c4 going for this strong
dark square Bishop threatening to double
up blacks pawns on the D file this row
back to e7 and now Bishop captures B
captures and f3 so what do we have here
correction does have the open B file but
this is the idea when you play b3 the
open B file doesn't really doesn't
really do anything and you kind of
messed up black's pawn structure but
then again this C pawn can become useful
once black pushes d5 it will it will you
know be a nice support to the center so
we have castles by nook by kurakin and F
characters on e4 Knight chapters on e4
and Knight to f3 and here was actually a
critical moment in the game where
Kerrigan could have practically I'm not
gonna say win the game but he played
Bishop to f6 but there was a move Bishop
to a6 now you're not just threatening to
capture on c4 and mess up White's pawn
structure
you're also not allowing white to castle
if if white castles for example castles
simply push d5 and after Knight C to e5
you capture the rook Bishop captures now
okay you do have this Knight to c6
attacking the Queen and the bishop but
after Queen moves Knight captures Queen
captures simply capture the bishop on F
on f1 you can't capture upon a D - the
knight is protecting it and white it
doesn't really have compensation here so
this Bishop to a6 would have been a
better move than the one Cara can plate
that is Bishop to f6
so Bishop captures my nakamora 90 actors
and castles by nakamura now kurakin goes
for Bishop to a6 we have d3 Bishop
captures B captures and the
five now so this position is now about
equal but but that previous position
where I showed you [ __ ] to a six that
was much much better for black so see
captures see captures and night to d4
now Queen to e7 now Knight to f5 kicking
the Queen away Queen e5 and queen to f3
we have g6 kicking the night away Knight
back to d4 King g7 as the knight was
attacked on f6 rook a to b 1 now
assuming the open B file and c5 again
developing in the center pushing pawns
forward and kicking the night away from
d4 Knight to b3 and rook F to e8 going
for that III pawn threatening to capture
it with check so King to H 1 this is
indirectly defending it since if you
capture the pawn you lose the knight on
f6 would check C for now D captures on
c4 and here Kerrigan like automatically
recapture the point D captures on c4 but
with a move like rook a to c8 this is
actually perfectly fine for black and if
blue if you capture C caps and e5 simply
roped the c3 you're threatening to
capture now on e3 and this is excellent
for black but after D captures on c4
carrageenan recaptures d captures on c4
and now Knight to d4
rook a to c8 now and rook the b7 and
this is a this is a very problematic
position for black when when this night
the d4 was played and a camera is
actually threatening rook to b5 to kick
the Queen away from the defense of the
night and hurricane kind of stops this
which rook 8 the c8 but he doesn't
really the idea was if ruk ruk b5 then
this roof can come to it come to c5 and
here Nakamura plays rook to b7 but when
in fact instead of this rook the b5 was
a much better move now if you play
something like Queen to d6 you still
have to defend the f6 Knight then you
have this rope to a5 move and you can't
capture if you capture the rook Knight
captures on f5 and you fork the king and
the Queen
so you would have to probably move the
night you'll lose the f7 pawn and end
the game but okay have to locate the c8
Nakamura went for Rupe the b7 and now a
five rope to b6 now definitely attacking
this night and f6 you can't defend it
you can't bring any ropes to the defense
the night is covering both squares so
Knight to e4 now Queen captures on f7
would check King h8 and now rook to b7
here nakamura threatens checkmate on h7
Knight to g5 would attempt on the Queen
and also defending the h7 Square Queen
to f2 and here Kerrigan I mean nakamura
is much better here but you know you can
still hold on
for example Kirk and played rook to e7
and this was actually the move that
loses the game instantly but who would a
move like Knight to e4 it's you know it
really forces white to find some sort of
a plan you're attacking the Queen and it
doesn't matter if you play Queen to f3
you kind of do want to keep your queen
on the F file if you play Queen f3 or
Queen to f7 any other Square will simply
allow carbine to exchange Queens again
Knight to g5 will attack both f3 + f7
kick the Queen away and again guard h7
so this might have been a way for
correcting to prolong it or or maybe
even continue playing on equal terms who
knows but after Queen f2
he played rook to e7 and this allowed
Nakamura Dean Stan Knight to c6
attacking the rook the Queen and you
can't you can't capture the knight of
course if you captured the night then
Queen to f8 this is checkmate
so after Knight to c6 car can had to
play something and there really isn't a
good move here he played he played
Knight to h3 and after this Knight to h3
the idea behind Knight to h3 is that if
you capture GG actress and h3 then Queen
d5 check Queen G to capture capture and
then rook captures rook and b7 and now
Kerrigan has a winning endgame he's up
the exchange and all the bones are
scattered for white cleric and I don't
think Carlton would have the slightest
problem winning the same game but after
Knight to h3
Nakamura see
played Queen to f3 now he's attacking
the knight he's protecting his knight on
c6 he's also still attacking the rook
and the Queen and there really isn't a
good move here to play so yeah
in this position Sergey kirkin resigned
the game and like I said nakamura won
this section with five five points to
four four points so in the end the total
result was three points for four Hikaru
Nakamura a very close match and you know
I'm really I don't know I thought I
actually thought Nakamura would would
win this with a with a higher result but
then again you know sir Sergei is one
strong player yeah I would like to thank
Felix the Winship for a contribution to
my channel think a lot I really
appreciate it and like I said on the
first on the 3rd of January we will see
the finals of the speed chess
championship between Magnus Carlsen
Hikaru Nakamura the same two finalists
who played last year and it was you know
it was really the ultimate showdown so
yeah as usual you can check to my
previous videos here thank you all for
watching and I will see you soon and
hope you still have a great Sunday